hey I'm huh cement Hodge I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm here to read you're
thirsty tweets this is the is this the
jug of thirst this is kind of gross it
says 100 ounces of satisfaction
guaranteed super inappropriate is fun
hustling menage is quite possibly the
most beautiful person alive physically
emotionally politically and spiritually
I dig your vibe bro amen
dig your vibe to feel like this guy is a
yoga instructor are these real tweets
that you guys found yeah I think this is
safer work you can you can you don't
have to have the headphones that I work
for this one okay Hudson Minaj is like
the most stunningly sexy man I've ever
seen on TV and the fact that he has a
show on Netflix discussing current
events in such an intelligent and
informative way Cruz you can find you a
man who can do both what are the two
things discussing current events by
being intelligent and informative
festive those are the two requirements
needed to I think my wife would disagree
she's even if I'm intelligent
informative she's like you need to
change the sheets but I appreciate I
appreciate your kind words the husband
meh not just so hot there's only one gag
I want from him all right that's not
appropriate I'm just gonna throw that
away
the only gags I do or chuckles yucks the
things I'd let Husson Minaj do to me his
brain is just mom and he's so easy on
the eyes
Allah really did that huh God he got
religious at the end he brought him God
at the end of this thirst weed that's
just come on dude don't bring God into
it don't bring that line to this man
come on bro I hope you didn't do this on
a Friday Friday's not a good day to be
Thursday Hasan Minhaj is so attractive
it's distracting me from learning about
the broken policing system come on you
have to focus on the broken policing
system it's awful pretty sure the last
thought I had before falling asleep was
Husson minaj expose my I'm not gonna
even read that I'm not gonna read that
expose my you guys can fill the rest in
I'm not gonna do that I am married I'm
happily married I want both a cam and B
cam to pick that
I'm only exposing one person's whatever
you think that I just want to ride
Husson and I just dick off into this
we're not going to do that one this
happening this isn't you guys are insane
you're putting this out into the public
I'm more concerned about you God
whenever I see how samanage I want to
make out with him slap him and give him
a xanax but never more than so when he's
talking about supreme and high peace oh
my god make out slap an ex what are
people doing these days I mean am i I'm
a prude I think I'm a prude cuz we're
making out I'm getting hit and you're
gonna give me a downer this has all been
a learning experience for me because I
just recently found out that Millennials
are really into eating but like that's
the thing that's the wave so I'm
learning a lot learning a lot okay
Millennials get we're gonna we have to
figure out climate change and not
getting hand foot and mouth disease
because we're all apparently out here
eating ass hustling makes my all right
we're not gonna do this I don't know it
says do you know what this word is yeah
Husson makes my [ __ ] quiver oh I
thought they misspelled puss it makes my
butt quiver okay I'll take that all
right I'm so glad that I can make make
your [ __ ] quiver I'm learning alive I'm
learning a lot today I had 10 orgasms
while watching Husson min I just and up
on Netflix you know the the stand-up
special is actually kind of like sad and
emotional but whatever whatever gets you
off you guys should all go watch Hasan
Minhaj a show on Netflix you should I
agree with that
it's called Patriot Act mm-hmm the show
is funny informative and oozing with
brown-skinned sex appeal I'm losing you
guys straight up losing
why couldn't Hudson manhaj have been the
sexy hero and the spy who dumped me they
did him so dirty you thrown the shade at
Sam Sam was great Sam such that sexy
hero he's great in it this is from a
verified account to we're doing photos
now it says hustle man Hodges the daddy
estuve all daddies
and then the jiff is I said what I said
uh yeah online
I've been called daddy I've been called
daddy guys in the comments below just
tell me what the difference in of daddy
and his daddy is is a D and upgrade on a
daddy
cuz I'm legally a daddy just comment
below let me know what is Thaddius yo my
baby daddy huh cement house killed the
game with his new show the Patriot Act
I certainly hope I'm not your baby daddy
not only are you teaching me about
something and making me feel all
informed pinchy but I get to look at
your fine ass the whole time hashtag
sign me the thank you if I can't marry
my crush and I can't marry huh Simon
hush then I guess I'm not getting
married get married it's fun there's so
many other guys that look exactly like
me out there go to Queens right now
there's like 50 guys that look like me
same haircut same beard literally
thousands of us walking around get
married it's fun it's awesome thank you
guys so much
please watch Patriot Act on Netflix and
I definitely have to clear the internet
history of my brain
[Music]